[Music]
my name is Bryan Gainey four years ago I
weighed almost 600 pounds and was
$60,000 in debt my eating and my
spending were completely out of control
I own American Express alone over
$17,000 then I had a wake-up call I
almost lost my life because of my weight
I was offered free weight loss surgery
but I turned it down
I had to do it on my own I took matters
into my own hands I started working a
modified version of the baby steps when
it came to my weight loss I started
walking short distances pretty soon I
was entering 5ks and 10ks and later on I
joined a gym I measured weighed and
wrote down my calories every day and
then I began to realize that overeating
and overspending are closely related
they're almost the same thing once my
weight-loss journey was underway I began
my Total Money Makeover I shredded my
credit cards the net point on I paid for
everything with cash I cancelled my
cable I quit eating out I bought my
clothes at the thrift store people made
fun of me I stayed home on the weekends
when all my friends were going out every
extra dollar I could find that I made
went toward the debt I got gizelle
intense I'd be out walking getting
exercise I'd find money on the ground
I'd collect the coins and deposit them
at the credit union and then send it all
to the credit card companies and now
after a slow and steady four years I
have lost nearly 400 pounds on my own
without any special diets or surgery
it's been hard work none of it was easy
I still have to work at it every day
because there is temptation everywhere
in America normal means broke but it
also means overweight but now I can
finally scream at the top of my lungs
I'm dead free but I have so much more
because I really am free
I can do whatever I want
and that American Express card well
guess what it's paid off
I don't know anybody a cent I started a
blog on the internet about my story
I even published a book because if you
live like no one else later you can live
like no one else cords your milestone
videos horizontally like this and then
upload them to Dave Ramsey comm slash
cut the cards don't worry about the
music we'll add that and then we'll
upload it to our video channel to
encourage others as well you and
thousands of others like you are
reaching new milestones every day
congratulations
don't give up and keep going until the
day that you can finally say
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]